This has been a seismic political event.
It wasn't expected, but then again,
there always was something in Leo Veracca's political personality
that suggested a day like this.
You couldn't fully rule it out.
What this government was looking at was a major test
in the local and European elections,
and particularly
in the aftermath of a trouncing in the two recent referendums.
Diddly Overadker have the stomach really far that fight.
When he speaks fairly candidly
and what was a fairly emotional announcement.
A short time ago,
he said on reflection there was personal and political reasons,
but he didn't feel that he was the best person for the job anymore.
Now you couldn't say that.
Forces within government were beginning to circle against him,
but he was facing a major challenge in the weeks ahead.
He's decided to depart before that,
and it would normally be expected
that he may have waited for those local and European election results.
He didn't do so. He's gone early.
He always said he was gonna leave politics by 50.
While he's been true to his word on that,
what's gonna happen next is interesting.
The tarnished insist this government can stay on the road,
that it still has a mandate
and that it can elect
something that didn't seem possible at all in Irish politics up to
quite recently.
That is a third t shook during the lifetime of an administration.
Who's that gonna be? Well,
we'll know by the 6th. Of april.
That's when Finigale will hold its ardesh.
The front runner right now
is unquestionably the higher education minister,
Simon Harris. If it goes to plan,
if things go along those expected lines,
well, then
on April 13th, he would become fishoke.
If he was elected by the Dawn.
And right now the government has a majority.
The tarnish and sister still has a mandate.
The opposition will take a very different view,
and no doubt, and raise questions about its stability.
At the same time,
things now beginning to push toward the 2025 general election.